alright I'd like to can you hear me I'd
like to thank the organizers for
inviting me here today to pay our
respects to dick and celebrate his many
contributions to our field of course as
dicks PhD student I learned a great deal
about research from dick and I think
Sanjeev and provoker captured well dicks
philosophy of concreteness and utility
and I think I've taken that with me
throughout my career even through a sort
of midlife crisis where I made a big
change and started working on quantum
computation which arguably isn't the
most practical of choices I think I've
taken that philosophy with me and I also
learned a great deal from dick about
teaching and to this day whenever I am
preparing a lecture I have in my mind
that gold standard that dick set for us
of these beautiful crisp and clear
lectures and i am still striving to
reach that gold standard today getting
better all the time but i'm still
striving for it and of course i think
we're all here today partly because
dicks many contributions have really
shaped what our field is today and so
even though some of us may not have had
the pleasure of working directly with
dick or taking his classes were really
all the beneficiaries of his enormous
influence so so speaking of which i'm
going to start with turn this on i'm
going to start with something that we
all know and that we've come to
understand the class NP as the class of
problems for which a yes instance can be
verified deterministically given the
proper witness to it and of course our
first NP complete problem was an
important first step but really a
complexity class derives its importance
from the significance of the problems
that are complete for that class so idea
which dick pioneered and so it was
really when dick showed those first 21
combinatorial problems that are complete
that we understood exactly the central
role that this idea would play in our
field and since then of course the rest
is history literally thousands of
problems have followed suit from every
branch of engineering and science so
so when Alexa Kataya introduced the
class qma it really felt like a very for
those of us in computer science it was
really a very natural generalization of
idea that was already very fundamental
for us so what's the difference between
the two complexity classes well I've
replaced my classical string that serves
as the witness now with a quantum state
it stored in a quantum register and now
the verification process is carried out
by a quantum computation polynomial time
quantum computation and the NP is
replaced by the class Merlin Arthur
because quantum computations by its very
nature has two sided error to it so this
verification process is necessarily
going to have two sided error so catia
when he first introduced the class also
gave us our first qm a complete problem
which is the local Hamiltonian problem
so I'm going to tell you a little bit
about that problem to define it ok so in
local Hamiltonian we have a set of
particles I've drawn them here as qubits
so they can be up or down in the 0 1
state or any quantum superposition of
the two but they could be potentially
finite dimensional particles and
constant size clusters of these
particles interact in some way so let's
just focus for a second on a particular
little cluster I've shown a cluster of
three cubits ok so the dimension of the
space is H 2 to the 3 and the energy
interaction of these three little cubics
is described by a linear operator and if
I diagonalize this matrix a basic
postulate of quantum mechanics says if
this is my little free cubic system and
I measure the energy of this system then
afterwards the result of the energy that
I'm going to get is one of the eigen
values of this matrix and after the
measurement the state is going to be in
a quantum superposition that corresponds
to the eigenvector corresponding to that
eigenvalue ok so this is one of the
basic postulates I shown here an energy
in the middle of the spectrum but here's
the ground energy the lowest possible
energy that I could get so this is the
lowest possible energy of my little
system and the corresponding vector is
the
ground state the lowest possible energy
state that it can be in okay so now I
don't just have three little cubits I
have a whole bunch of them okay and
clusters are interacting so I have a
number of constant size clusters and
their energy interaction defined okay
and the and the Hamiltonian is the sum
of all these little local terms and the
goal is to find the global quantum state
that minimizes the total energy of my
system ok so it's an eigenvalue problem
the Hamiltonian has a very succinctly
some of local terms but if I expand it
out say i have n qubits in my system
it's really a 2 to the N by 2 to the n
matrix so it's an eigenvalue eigenvector
problem on a really large matrix ok and
if I want to phrase this as a decision
problem I'm asking is the energy less
than some threshold or is it bigger than
some threshold instance these are real
numbers we have to pay a little
attention to precision I'm given some
promise gap which is one over polynomial
and the size of my why quantum system
alright so if it just so happens that
each one of these local terms is already
diagonalized in the 0-1 basis this is
exactly the constraint satisfaction
problem so each of those diagonal
entries tells me the cost of those three
bits being in that configuration ok and
the goal is to find the global classical
state that minimizes the total cost ok
so it's a very natural generalization of
a problem that we're quite familiar with
already ok but we don't just make a
quantum version of something for the
sake of making a quantum version of it
as dick showed us back in 72 and P is
important because of the importance of
the problems that are complete for the
class and similarly the same case is
true for local Hamiltonian now qma
doesn't have the same rich array of
complete problems that NP has but the
local Hamiltonian problem itself is a
really central problem in condensed
matter physics and
if you look at a lot of the work that
takes place in computational physics
looking at quantum many-body systems to
some degree a lot of this activity is
focused on finding ground states and
ground energies okay so instead of just
telling this to you I want to give you a
particular example to give you a little
bit of a flavor for the kinds of
questions that are of interest there so
I picked this particular example because
one of the authors Steve white is a
colleague of mine in the physics
department at UC Irvine and his office
is a few buildings down and he was
willing to sit with me and explain his
paper to me so that's how I chose this
particular example so we have a
beautiful lattice structure he recalled
the kagame lattice okay and sitting at
the vertices of this lattice are cubits
01 quantum variables and pairs of qubits
interact wherever there's an edge
between two qubits there's an
interaction okay and the physics of this
interaction is described by this little
4 by 4 matrix it's a very well studied
model called the Heisenberg
antiferromagnetic so if you notice for
example the on the diagonal the 0 0 1 1
have a positive entry showing that
there's an energy penalty for spins
being aligned okay and a negative for
the 01 10 showing that the system tends
to want to be anti aligned okay and the
off diagonal terms sort of demonstrate
movement indicating that the ground
state is going to be some quantum
superposition of the of the two okay so
it's a frustrated system we have you
know odd length cycles and things want
to be anti aligned okay so the basic
question that they were asking in their
paper and there'll interested in the
behavior of this model on an infinite 2d
lattice okay so the basic question that
they wanted to answer is what's the
structure of the ground state so it's
essentially a local Hamiltonian problem
of as I've described it so one
possibility that it's a valence bond
crystal and I showed little clusters of
two but a valence bond crystal are
clusters are periodic pattern of
clusters of qubits that are locally
entangled but not entangled with each
other okay so there's a broken symmetry
all
nativ Lee is it a spin liquid and a spin
liquid is a is a kind of a special state
of matter that's not completely well
understood but if you do any measurement
on a spin liquid it appears completely
disordered much like a liquid so there's
no broken symmetries in the state
however there's a lot of believed to be
a lot of quantum structure and v2
underneath that we don't uncomplete ly
understand so for example it's
conjectured that these are created by
quantum superpositions of different
valence bond structures that sort of
washes away the symmetry okay it's a
state of matter that's not very well
understood and there are particular
interest for various reasons one of the
reasons is is that the the low-lying
excited states of these systems exhibit
very interesting physics so the these
low-level excited states the the whole
collection of particles are best
mathematically is described as weakly
interacting quasiparticles and these
particles have interesting physics that
you don't normally see so they can have
fractional charges in different
statistics so there was a while we're
there was conjectured that spin liquids
there's a are important for
high-temperature superconductors Alexei
Kataya has proposed a model of quantum
computation which would use these
quasiparticles to actually compute in
low low lying States and it's believed
that this might be a more stable
substrate for a quantum computer so
regardless of the applications it seems
to be an important feature of physics
that's not well understood and people
are trying to understand it better and
it seems it's interesting because it
seems that two dimensions seems to be a
sweet spot of complexity and you see
more of this interesting physics in the
two dimensional models so at any rate so
Steve writes on this paper a key problem
in searching for spin liquids and 2d
models is that there's no exact or
nearly exact analytical or computational
methods to solve infinite to the quantum
lattice systems so there's really not
successful heuristics in this in this
area so it's a reasonable question if
you had a quantum computer would it help
you solve this problem okay
and I guess more generally we believe
that if we could build a quantum
computer that it would be useful for
problems in the physical sciences in
which you have to model or simulate
quantum phenomena things in material
science problems from computational
chemistry or condensed matter physics
and it would be very nice to flesh out
this agenda a little bit more because we
don't really understand exactly how a
quantum computer could help in this in
this department so so I'm going to tell
you a little bit about the state of the
art most of it is hardness results but
there are few glimmers of positive
positive hope in there so so here's a
picture that you're all familiar with
here's the famous tableau showing that
the computation of a Turing machine is
can be used as an instance the
satisfiability can be used to to capture
the the computation of a Turing machine
ok and each each row of course is a
state of the Turing machine time goes
from top to bottom and our instance of
boolean satisfiability each has there
are these little pieces of finite logic
that each enforce the fact that if this
is going to be an accepting if it's a
satisfying assignment that it has to
accurately model the progress of the
touring machine ok so we know this this
well and until made the quick the
picture is very similar ok but instead
of having this 2d tableau structure
we're showing the we're showing a static
object which is the quantum state that
represents a dynamic quantum computation
and now each step of the computation is
expressed in quantum superposition so
this this this computation state was
first suggested by five min and 86 so
this would be akin to the satisfying
assignment for the tableau so each each
particular state in my super position
represents one step in a quantum circuit
say ok and they're all expressed in
quantum
quantum superposition the clock is
expressed in unary and sort of keeps the
different slices of the the time steps
in different parts of the hilbert space
so the hamiltonian is a sum of local
terms that enforces that a low energy
state corresponds in this way to a valid
accepting computation of my quantum
verifier okay and so how much logic do i
need to actually enforce this well it
turns out that operations on five cubits
are sufficient so I need to some of the
qubits on the right are the computation
cubits the key it's on the left of the
clock and it says well if my clock is in
state I then I need to implement the IP
gate okay so the theorem that can't I
approved is that five local Hamiltonian
is qm a complete so this is a in some
ways exactly the picture that Sanjeev
showed us this morning where you have a
family of practical problems that you
want to solve we've drawn a big circle
around it a very general problem and we
shown something else to be difficult in
that class okay so a lot of the
subsequent results are the the process
of sort of tightening the circle around
the family problems that we really want
to solve okay so the first step is I if
you look at the this picture here
there's no it's called local Hamiltonian
but there's no physical locality
happening here at all the qubits are
scattered and I'm just picking a five of
them and operating on them okay so the
first step is actually to talk about
these particles being laid out in some
finite dimensional space so the first
step was to show that even if my my
particles are laid out on a 2d grid and
i only have pairwise interactions it's
still a hard problem okay and the idea
is it's still the same quantum
superposition state the ground state the
particles are now finite dimensional
particles and the clock and the control
is sort of now distributed through my
system so each particle encodes part of
the computation was that's going on and
part of the control that's that's
happening okay this was then improved to
actually qubits on in two dimensions
where where each of these find out
particles is now replaced by a gadget on
qubits
and then finally even in one dimensions
even on a line the problem is difficult
so this was interesting for a couple
reasons and a little bit surprising
first of all this differs from the
classical picture because we know that
constraint satisfaction and 2d is hard
and on a line you can just use dynamic
programming for it so and the thing that
we can get away with in quantum is that
there's a lot of rich information in a
quantum superposition okay so we're
actually still encoding a lot in that
quantum superposition another reason why
it was somewhat surprising is that in 2d
on physicists their heuristics are still
quite unsuccessful on 2d systems but
we're very successful in 1d so for the
physicists 1d was solved and it wasn't
problematic so it's a little surprising
that was still difficult and it was
later explained partly by the fact that
if your Hamiltonian has a gap between
the lowest and the next highest excited
state you actually can solve the problem
in polynomial time so that helps to
understand why heuristic alee physicists
were having better better success for
these systems okay another way in which
these vary dramatically from the kagome
lattice that that steve and his
colleagues were trying to solve is that
this is obviously a carefully engineered
instances that we're showing are
difficult so if you look at the local
constraint between particle i minus 1
and I it's completely different than the
local constraint between particle I and
I plus 1 because these are being used to
actually implement the gates of a
circuit okay so we're saying you know
implement this skate here that gate here
so it's a very carefully engineered
construction so what about
translationally invariant systems so we
don't even know exactly yet how to how
to define even talked about a family
complexity classes here but here's a
definition that that that helps us get a
little closer to it so I'm going to
define as a part of my problem
description the dimension of the
particle and the interaction term so
that's given as part of the problem just
like the physicist would study you know
Heisenberg model on a kagame lattice
okay that's part of the problem the
input is just an integer okay so that's
all you have in the
put and then you asked if I were to have
a line of particles and apply this term
on each pair and the line has n
particles in it what's the ground energy
of the system ok so this is sort of
captures this this this translationally
invariant feature ok and as it turns out
this is also hard ok now i have qmax and
the reason i have x is that the the
witnesses and the verification process
is exponentially long because now my my
input is exponentially shorter because
i'm coding it in binary so I'm
interested in things that are polynomial
in the size of the system ok so it
appears that this is also hard now I've
drawn here this schematic but Willie
this is a better picture of what it
looks like because the dimension of
these particles is constant but it's
really only a constant that a
theoretician would love you know it's
really a big it's a big number so we are
this this ain't no qubits or if we're
far we're far from the sort of more
practical models that the physicists are
interested in so you can ask well what
about natural Quantum's models and what
can you say about the hardness as those
which is really kind of what we're
getting at at the other end of the
spectrum there are their results that
actually look at very natural well
studied physical terms so I'm defining
the term between two particles to be one
of the most simple models that
physicists study and if I allow my graph
structure now to be more complex than
it's still hard so you can encode the
the quantum circuit itself in the
structure of the graph and it's
difficult ok so we have hard graphs but
simple interaction terms simple graphs
hard interaction terms and we'd really
like to know what's sitting in between
okay so everything here has been bad
news so far so is there anything
positive we can say a few things we can
so one of the early results in quantum
algorithms is that you can actually
simulate the time dynamics of a quantum
system using a quantum computer so we
know from one another possibility of
quantum mechanics is that the time
evolution is governed by Schrodinger's
equation and this is that same energy
Hamiltonian here and I've shown the
solution here for a time
independent Hamiltonian that doesn't
change and if it's local then given a
starting state you can actually estimate
this time evolution it still leaves us
with the problem of finding a natural or
physical starting state in all of
Hilbert space so this still remains a
problem and I've also only focused on
ground states ok so in higher
temperatures the state of our system is
sitting in a probability distribution
over states governed governed by the
Gibbs distribution so the probability of
some state is proportional to this
exponential function and we have the
temperature t which represents
temperature so in high temperatures this
converges to a totally uniform
distribution in very low temperatures
the energy is emphasized and it's and
it's peaked at the low energy states but
we'd like to be able to sample from the
skids distribution in between ok and of
course there's been a lot of work in
this community looking at classical
models like the Ising model and
understanding the convergence rate of of
Markov chains so in the physics
committee a go to algorithm for this
this is widely used for classical models
is the metropolis algorithm in which
you're sitting at a state you tweak it a
little bit to get another state and then
you decide to go to that state with some
fixed probability proportional to
exponential and the difference of the
two energies so this has been very
successful used heuristic alee within
within the physics community as well as
analyzed within our community as well
for four classical models now what about
implementing that using a quantum
computer so here this we're doing
exactly the same thing we're trying to
find a classical distribution governed
by gibbs but the underlying states that
were walking on our quantum states okay
so they're these quantum I ghen ghen
vectors of our system okay so just to
store a single state where we sitting in
principle could you could require a
quantum register and a quantum computer
just to represent the object itself and
so we'd like to do implement exactly
that same algorithm we'd like to be able
sitting in a state tweak it and make the
decision about whether to go or not and
we don't know much about convergence but
even implementing this algorithm is
problematic on a quantum computer and
the reason is is you you're sitting at a
state you tweak it in some way and now
you have some quantum superposition of
where you might go to if you decide to
take this step in order to decide
whether you take the step you have to
perform a quantum measurement of some
kind okay and quantum computation is
reversible except when you do a
measurement okay so the main
contribution of this paper is the fact
that they give away to actually reverse
if you decide to reject the move how you
go back and it's they usually a
beautiful trip by Mariette and mantras
of iteratively sampling that gets you
back to your original state so the
accomplishment here is just that you can
implement metropolis algorithm and this
does converge to to the Gibb state that
you'd like to be able to sample from but
we know almost nothing about convergence
okay so it's really wide open whether
this is actually efficient and for which
systems that's efficient so in terms of
you know provable bonds we know almost
nothing but this could prove to be a
useful heuristic as it has in the in the
classical case in the quantum community
so we spent the last few decades thanks
to dick since 1972 coping with NP
completeness and I suggest that we spend
at least part of the future decades
coping with you may complete this so
thank you and happy birthday
well in this tie game but in the in the
in the quantum metropolis algorithm
paper they make this claim well this
algorithm will converge quickly whenever
nature does I mean there's not really
much of a formal basis for that but it's
possible that there are natural systems
where it doesn't actually converge so
it's not clear that we actually get to
the to the true Gibbs distribution you
mean actual physical experiment and then
comparing comparing it with the actual
presumably we need the quantum computer
first though I guess